bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct ravi de vous retrouver au
sommaire ce soir la gauche et les
socialistes après les écologistes après
les communistes c'était au tour des
socialistes de discuter ce matin avec
les insoumis mais sur quelles bases
accords de coalitions programmatique ou
tambouille politicienne l'union de la
gauche introuvable à la présidentielle
était cette fois à portée de main et
puis jean luc mélenchon en position de
force at il vraiment intérêt à des
alliances du rouge du vert du rose et
beaucoup dé pin c'est notre grand débat
dans un instant sur ce plateau notre
grand témoin propose des remèdes à la
grande fatigue démocratique qui s'est
emparée de notre pays après la
présidentielle pas de doute pour elle il
est urgent de revoir complètement notre
mode de scrutin porter à ses yeux de
faux plaisi plébiscite nous verrons
quelles sont les solutions novatrices
pour lesquels elle milite dans plusieurs
associations elles s'appellent chloé
ridel à 30 ans et elle est avec nous ce
soir enfin nous retrouverons nos a
franchi ils sont 2 de parti pris ce soir
celui de joseph macé scaron qui va nous
révéler la recette des législatives
c'est la cuisson à l'étouffée et vincent
hugeux qui élargit la focale sur poutine
dictateur pour l'europe en moi pour
l'afrique voilà pour mener ce soir
n'oubliez pas à ce tag cvr merci
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs mais que se passe-t-il à
gauche pour les législatives fort de ses
presque 8 millions de voix le troisième
homme de la présidentielle jean-luc
mélenchon serait-il redevenu
fréquentable on va essayer d'y voir un
peu plus clair avec mes invités trois
femmes de gauche de trois parties bien
différent en trois partie compensés
irréconciliables vous allez nous dire si
il se reparlent et commence ce soir
bonsoir mano aubry bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous députée européenne la france
insoumise vous étiez ce matin à la
réunion au siège de la france info mise
avec les différents représentants du
parti socialiste vous nous direz ce qui
s'est passé comment se passe justement
ces discussions bonsoir laurence
rossignol bonsoir bienvenue sénatrice
socialiste du val d'oise vous êtes
bourgeoise dieu de l'oise pardonnez moi
vous êtes aujourd'hui proche d'arnaud
montebourg toujours et vous avez soutenu
anne hidalgo pendant la présidentielle
après le retrait de votre candidat de la
course bonsoir sandrine rousseau ancien
merci d'être avec nous écologistes etc
aux féministes membre d'europe écologie
les verts candidate aux législatives
dans la 9e circonscription de paris on
peut le dire ce soir il ya un flou
autour de votre investiture vous allez
nous dire ce qu'il en est ce soir si
c'est définitif ou pas clos et ridel je
vous le disais dans le sommaire va nous
rejoindre comme notre grand témoin ce
soir elle est cofondatrice de l'institut
rousseau et de l'association mieux vaut
t elle nous rejoint dans un instant mais
d'abord pour nous planter le décor comme
chaque soir j'appelle mon camarade
stéphane blakowski si j'ai bien compris
les négociations avancent plus vite que
prévu on l'a tout de suite
[Musique]
bonsoir stéphane consorts myriam bonsoir
à tout si j'ai bien compris ce soir si
j'ai bien compris myriam jean luc
mélenchon rêve d'être premier ministre
c'est marqué en gros sur la fiche on ne
peut pas se tromper un mélenchon premier
ministre lloyd amont d'un point de vue
psychologique on peut se dire bon c'est
pas un petit peu de la mégalomanie mais
moi je préfère l approche marketing et
de ce point de vue je trouve que c'est
assez bien j'ai aussi quand on est une
grande marque et qu'on veut inspirer la
confiance à ses consommateurs on peut
faire des grands discours mais le mieux
serait d'avoir une personnalité qui
incarne des valeurs on appelle ça une
égérie donc l'égérie de l'union
populaire c'est jean luc mélenchon et
clémentine autain qu'est la responsable
marketing j'imagine indue des insoumis
explique soit plutôt bien en fait pour
des millions de français c'est concret
tiers là d'un seul coup revoit on se dit
oui si jean luc mélenchon et premier
ministre alors toute une série de
mesures que nous avons proposé pour être
être mises en oeuvre voilà c'est ça
l'objet ces deux êtres compris d'une
majorité de français qui pourraient être
démobilisés l'occasion ces élections
législatives et alors cette affiche elle
pose surtout jean luc mélenchon comme le
patron incontesté de toute la gauche il
prend beaucoup de place sur la fille on
peut même dire toute la place sur la
fiche et donc ça agace surtout ceux qui
prenait beaucoup de place avant on les
appelle les éléphants oui c'est énorme
mais qui prennent énormément de place
dans premier secrétaire du ps
jean-christophe cambadélis
il était ce matin sur france info lui
pas question que ça soit mélenchon le
patron hassan on nous propose pas une
coalition nous propose une reddition
regardez jean luc mélenchon a déjà lancé
sa campagne en disant que c'était lui le
futur premier ministre il a sorti
plusieurs centaines de aussi ce n'est
millions de tracts pour
rentrer en campagne alors que les
négociations ne sont pas commencé donc
vous voyez bien qu'on se moque un peu de
nous non elles sont entamées
il ya eu un vote donc ils sont 245 au
bureau national 160 voix pour 75 voix
contre il se trouve que dans les bois
contre on reparle vous savez de ces
énormes animaux qui prennent beaucoup de
place des éléphants il ya quand même
illégaux il ya quand même hollande ce
qui fait qu'au delà du conflit
idéologique qui existent certainement eu
aussi un peu un conflit de générations
pierre jouvet qui est le négociateur qui
va parler aux insoumis à 35 ans ce matin
il était sur sud radio on lui a demandé
un petit peu ce qu'ils pensent fait ça
alors si vous avez des grandes oreilles
des défenses étaient vous ouverture de
la chasse à l'éléphant qui a fait dans
ce pays que la gauche qui étaient aux
responsabilité qui avait tous les
pouvoirs s'est retrouvé écroulé c'est
quand même pas la responsabilité de ma
génération de ces femmes et de ces
hommes que vous citiez tout à l'heure
donc à un moment moi je dis à ces
éléphants laissez-nous faire laissez
nous tranquilles vous avez saborder le
parti socialiste quand il était au plus
haut niveau maintenant laissez nous
allons chez top quoi oui mais là ça
suffit
voilà comment elle avançait négociations
même on pas enfin globalement les
insoumis ont plutôt raison d'être
satisfait quand ils entendent ce
discours donc il ya une négociation
aujourd'hui tout le monde a dit de
partir d'autres y avait moyen de
s'entendre et donc comme un noël bompas
a
pris la parole à 10 le ps a quand même
bien changé depuis quatre ans donc pour
ceux qui voulaient remercier olivier
faure non en fait il voulait plutôt
épinglé quelqu'un d'autre mais devinez
qui ce qu'on a observé c'est qu'il ya
clairement une volonté de
afficher une rupture avec le bilan qu'a
été celui de françois hollande on nous a
dit qu'il y avait pas de difficulté à
s'engager sur l'abrogation de la loi
elle comme rick avait pas de difficulté
à s'engager sur la 6ème république avait
pas de difficulté à s'engager sur le
blocage des prix de telle sorte que
honnêtement n'avais pas l'impression de
discuter avec le même parti socialiste
que il ya deux ou trois ans de ça bon
alors expliquez nous ça c'est les
socialistes du côté des verts elle
avance aussi les négociations commencent
à ce ballon revient cette histoire
d'afficher la fiche ça veut dire
mélenchon c'est le patron il y en a
comme jade au cours d'hier alors là moi
pas question courber l'échiné sandrine
rousseau devrait bien faire qui était
fort de souplesse
tellement pour réussir à s'entendre non
puis après il ya julien bayou quoi alors
je suis parti julien bayou qu'est ce
qu'ils en pensent alors vous allez me
retrouvais pénible mais on revient à
coire cette affiche qui je suis désolé
parce que lui sans problème sa pâque
mélenchon sur le patron son premier où
son parti s'il s'appelle europe ecologie
les verts donc déjà ça commence par
europe bon france info me c'est pas des
plus européen de la bande par les
répètes europe ecologie les verts le
deuxième os et écologie mais il est où
le mot écologie sur les fiches ou qu'il
est en écoute il ya notamment la
question de la stratégie parce que nous
disons nous on propose par exemple dire
union populaire écologistes on nous dit
non c'est l'union populaire et c'est à
dire le nom d'avoir le nom de votre
parti sur les affiches en reflet de
loyer qu'elle reflète l'idée d'une
coalition vous dit quoi on nous dit non
je sais pas pourquoi d'ailleurs y'a pas
de logo quand écologie les verts du poil
l'union populaire pourrait pas être
écologiste ou quoi donc vous voyez que
cette affiche de police le débat
mélenchon et ans entre toutes les
attentions donc ça c'est très bien vu
donc je profite pour faire un petit
recul flash-back 2017 vous souvenez je
vous rencontre les chiffres jean luc
mélenchon fait trois fois plus de voix
que benoît hamon dont trois fois plus de
voix que le parti socialiste à la
présidentielle aux législatives
ah mince deux fois moins de sièges mais
françois hollande c'est de sous-estimer
donc ne sous-estimé pas françois
hollande il doit s'exprimer d'ailleurs
demain sur ces négociations merci merci
stéphane pour votre regard l'on va
commencer avec les négociations du parti
socialiste laurence rossignol vous
voulez souhaitez vous souhaitez une
coalition qu'est ce que vous mettez dans
ce mot là il s'agit de d'un programme
commun négocié les deux parties doivent
lâcher en fait on parle comme une chose
assez sérieuse on parle de qui va ou
pourrait gouverner la france dans les
cinq ans qui viennent c'est à dire un
pays dont il a échappé à personne qu'il
était tendue en trois 3 tiers en
reprendre la facilement du lab rat tiers
à bloc voilà et dont 2/3 assez
orthogonaux d'ailleurs d'un autre côté
l'extrême droite et de l'autre côté tout
ce qui est autour de la gauche voilà ce
que valent n'est pas extrême gauche
enfin 22 plus le reste plus on arrive à
31 je crois c'est maryvonne à peu près
donc et puis les 28 % caf emmanuel
macron premier tour et ses deux tirs là
ne souhaite pas qu'elle manuel macron
conduisent la même politique que celle
qui l'a conduite pendant cinq ans même
si son score a été relativement élevé
lui aussi bénéficié d'un vote utile au
premier tour incontestablement il ya de
toute façon une forte opposition donc
c'est de la responsabilité de toutes les
formations de gauche d'essayer de
trouver des solutions pour le pays on va
parler des solutions sur le fond un
média brésilien globo regarde les
programmes qu'est ce que vous répondez à
jean christophe cambadélis qui parle de
de reddition il ya aussi stéphane le
foll un qui dit un accord avec mélenchon
se serait l'effacement finale du ps et
ça dépend de l'accord ça dépend de
l'accord en france la gauche a toujours
été divers c'est comme ça c'est la date
même d'avant le congrès tour déjà au
sein des socialistes avant congrès de
tours il y avait déjà des discussions et
des tendances donc la gauche est diverse
et à chaque fois qu'elle est arrivée au
pouvoir soit 36 81
97 et même 2012 où il y avait eu des
discussions importantes avec les
écologistes et un gouvernement avec des
sociétés d'écologistes à chaque fois qu
à gauche est arrivée au pouvoir c'est
parce qu'elle assure rassembler et faire
de sa diversité est la méthode mais à un
moment il faut quand même mettre
d'accord sur l'essentiel alors la
nécessité de prochains temps manuel
valls vous en souvenez l'origine quand
j'étais ministre de son gouvernement oui
vous avez vu aussi dans des réunions
politiques absolument il a théorisé les
gauches irréconciliables fallait je le
crois aujourd'hui je crois pas que les
caissières jésus diable je crois qu'il
ya des sujets qui sont des sujets
importants mais qui d'ailleurs traverse
un peu tout le monde à gauche on est en
train de discuter d'un accord qui
pourrait rassembler le parti communiste
et les écologistes et la france
insoumise les moyens de la transition
énergétique ne sont pas les mêmes la
parti communiste est incontestablement
favorable à l'accroissement du nucléaire
les eaux comme le parti socialiste hier
dans la sortie oui parce ce n'était pas
très clair à s'user moi là dessus mais
enfin bon c'est pas globalement la mildt
arnaud montebourg arnaud montebourg
hollande
arnaud montebourg effectivement part
globalement globalement avec amélie
l'objectif est de dire on sort du
pétrole dans les 30 ans à venir mais
pour passer cette sortie du pétrole on
peut pas se priver du nucléaire voilà ce
que en gros la doxa la plus communément
admise donc on connaît bien cette
diversité de la gauche elle a toujours
existé donc après la question de savoir
comment on réguler cette diversité dans
la méthode de construction d'une
coalition c'est pour ça que c'est pas la
même chose la coalition et le ralliement
parce que la méthode de réguler sa
d'intégration dans l'union populaire du
parti dans ce qu'elle m'a bien compagne
juste est juste un mot tout alain
manuellement par dizaines par ceux ci
sachent angers c'est pas les mêmes que
j'avais avant mais je pense sans moi
même à cet instant je lui mets ou s'ils
ont changé et quelques années avait plus
de droits plus de gauche avait plus que
le peuple bon on voulait plus dit même à
genlis alors j'avais vu changer
précisément
non aujourd'hui la discussion se fait
avec les formations de gauche ce n'est
plus simplement le peuple contre les
élites c'est aussi de la gauche qui doit
propre produire un projet contre macron
et contre l'extrême droite pour
gouverner pas juste un mot et c'est que
la manière dont on construit une
coalition elle dit la manière dont on
gouvernerait parce qu'une fois qu'on est
au pouvoir c'est que là où comme disait
françois mitterrand tout commence et les
difficultés commencent si on n'a pas mis
en place les modes de régulation dans un
pays qui est aussi tendue d'accord c'est
on n'y arrivera pas personne n'y
arrivera donc moi je suis favorable à
tout le crâne alors plus grand
rassemblement alessio ça veut dire voilà
une discussion sur le programme où
chacun doit un petit peu lâché du lest
pour arriver à un consensus c'est un peu
l'idée oui pis le respect par une raison
bien que ça leur giron des insoumis
c'est très clair je voulais vraiment
qu'on s'arrêtait là dessus on va venir
d'ailleurs sur le fond assure quoi vous
pouvez être d'accord ou pas d'abord je
salue l'entrée de colère est dérisoire
bonsoir vous êtes co fondatrice de
l'institut rousseau et 2 l'association
mieux voter on va parler avec vous tout
à l'heure de mode de scrutin de la crise
démocratique mais je suis sûr que vous
avez choses à nous dire votre regard
nous intéresse sur sur ces négociations
entre les différents partis de gauche
vous y étiez maintenant aubry on
aimerait bien savoir comment ça se passe
on ne sait pas où est ce que c'est la
carte des cirques hogan yable que vous
avez comme ça sur sur le bureau pas dit
un mot ce matin l avons pas parlé de
circonscription nous avons parlé de
politique au sens noble du terme
c'est-à-dire d'idées de projets et de
programmes et nous sommes partis d'un
nombre de points qui nous semblent
fondamentaux qui sont sur les ceux sur
lesquels nous avons fait campagne en
tant qu'union populaire et nous avons eu
ni 22% pour voir s'il pouvait y avoir
convergence grâce à une certaine partie
de gens de gauche qui n'était pas
forcément favorable à jean luc mélenchon
ça il le sait il y à il ya une partie de
l'union populaire mais des sondages qui
ont été faits sur l'électorat de jean
luc mélenchon c'est 80% par exemple de
d'adhésion au programme et c'est la
raison principale pour laquelle ils ont
voté l'union populaire et ce qui était
assez surprenant et je dois le dire et
c'est aussi pour ça que mon collègue
manuel bompard utilise ce terme de
nouveau parti socialiste puisque dans
ces marqueurs politiques fondamentaux il
y avait la 6ème république
il y avait le blocage des prix des
produits de première nécessité il y
avait la retraite à 60 ans il y avait
aussi retraite à 60 il y avait la
trouille les deux tours la journée à
benneteau s'est fait c'est ça le nouveau
talent et la question est à poser au
parti socialiste mais je fais des trois
centres de dalida y avait il y avait
aussi les lois travail et les lois elles
comrie et là c'est intéressant c'est
pour peut-être pour répondre à laurence
rossignol je pense que c'est la
différence par rapport à 2017 et 2022 en
2017 nous sortions du quinquennat
françois hollande qui a des facto on le
veuille ou non mais qui a des facto
fracturé la gauche et c'était difficile
j'imagine pour le parti socialiste à ce
moment-là de rompre avec une partie des
politiques de françois hollande comme
les noix travailler ce matin la
délégation du parti socialiste nous a
dit évidemment nous reviendrions là
dessus alors qu'est ce que le ps peut
apporter à jean luc mélenchon et aux
insoumis sur le fond pourquoi pourquoi
jean luc mélenchon accepte de négocier
ce qu'elles restent d'ailleurs sur la
retraite à 60 ans un moment ils nous ont
dit historiquement ça a été la position
du parti socialiste de gagner de
nouveaux droits sociaux et nous a dit et
on leur a dit eh bien bon retour à la
maison des droits sociaux et c'est assez
intéressant en fait et c'est d'ailleurs
de revenir sur votre programme non et
l'idée c'est pas dire on a raison et on
vous absorbe d'ailleurs à aucun moment
on demande un ralliement que les choses
soient très claires à europe ecologie
les verts au parti socialiste sont des
partis politiques qui ont par ailleurs
ali mais la vie politique de notre pays
sa dernière année à aucun moment rôles
sur quoi vous pouvez évoluer si c'est
une coalition c'est un peu de donnant
donnant alors oui on lui on l'a fait
aussi dans des proportions qui a été
jugé par les urnes c'est à dire il a
échappé à personne qu'aujourd'hui le
parti socialiste ps pas la même chose
que l'union populaire mais si on est
mauvais alors préfet les news de mesures
si on a ouvert des discussions c'est que
on est prêt à essayer de former un
gouvernement tout son centre donc on dit
pas les 694 proposition d'amiens en
commun c'est à prendre ou à laisser on
dit qu'on fait des priorités c'est pour
ça c'est ça qu'on a examiné ce matin
avec le parti socialiste sur une liste
de 12 points et de ce point de vue là
j'ai constaté qu'il ya un travail
sérieux programmatique qui a été fait
est une évolution de la part du parti
socialiste
bref assez complexe à lui que mémé fait
gilles ya un point sur lequel bas il ya
un pot vous avez évolué pour pourvoir
aux pc j'ose dire sur un certain nombre
de circonscriptions qui a fait beaucoup
débat qui à la question européenne dont
on sait qu'elle a fracturé la gauche
bien avant le quinquennat hollande
depuis 2005 et nous on a été très clair
en leur faisant la démonstration qu'une
partie des propositions qui pouvaient
être les nôtres en commun comme la
renationalisation d'edf comme le fait de
pouvoir garder dans le giron public la
sncf et l'ensemble des billes
deux rails comme la désobéissance au
score jalel possibilité d'un objet
arrive pourquoi c'est important c'est si
on veut faire un grand plan
d'investissement social écologique je
vous ai donné tous ces exemples si on
veut être concret réaliste ces mesures
là aujourd'hui elles sont en
contradiction avec les règles
européennes le parti socialiste est
d'accord avec cette analyse et ce sur
quoi nous devons travailler c'est la
méthode pour s'affranchir de ces
blocages pas parce qu'on n'aime pas
l'union européenne ou parce qu'on veut
désobéir pour désobéir mais bien comment
on lève ces blocages pour être en
capacité que ça ce sera l être la nôtre
de pression ça fait partie des actions
qu'il maintenait à tempérament on veut
former un gouvernement on peut pas dire
l'union européenne on n'en parle pas et
on le met de côté on prendrait les
électeurs pas au sérieux on va parler
des négociations avec les écologistes
mais c'est c'est un nouveau parti
socialiste vous vous l'avez vu vous
entre les deux tours de la
présidentielle
qui n'est plus social libéral social
démocrate qui a changé sur le fou vous
le voyez tous les cas c'est un parti
socialiste qui veut l'alliance donc
c'est bien dire que et c'est ça qui
change je pense profondément parce que
jusqu'à présent une alliance avec elle
est fille n'était quand même pas quelque
chose de gagner au sein de au sein du
parti socialiste a les noms d'oiseaux
sans bride oui oui et de parts et
d'autres bailleurs de l'est les troupes
amateurs traverse a eu deux noms
d'oiseaux vis-à-vis du parti socialiste
on a été vigilants
cette semaine
à aucun moment nous avons eu un mot
vis-à-vis d'anne hidalgo il c'est vrai
qu'un hidalgo nous a plutôt traités
comme des agents de poutine ce qui est
fait est fait et j'ai aussi compris que
ce n'était pas une île consensuel au
sein de la direction du parti socialise
a été dit sur un corner de la parole
sans dred rosso vous ça vous dérange pas
du tout de dire qu'il ya un leader
incontesté c'est jean luc mélenchon et
qu'au fond fort de ses 22 % c'est lui
qui pose les conditions ça vous semble
naturel c'est lui qui pose les
conditions on a droit de discuter aussi
20 je ne veux pas non plus mais
évidemment qu'il ya un leadership ouvert
là dessus moi j'ai pas de jets pas de
sujet c'est le premier tour de la
présidentielle après je dis juste à et
l'efym ils le savent aussi qu'il ya eu
une forme de déport des votes d'autres
candidats de la gauche verts jean luc
mélenchon et ça il faut l'analyser comme
quelque chose qui n'ont pas est une
attraction de jean luc mélenchon même si
de fait ça a augmenté son score mais
comme une volonté absolument farouche du
peuple de gauche et de l'écologie a
gagné dire que moi ce que je retiens
vraiment de cette de ce premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle c'est la
volonté très forte qu'on eut les
électeurs et électrices de gagner de
gagner l'accès au second tour et là
aujourd'hui de gagner les législatives
donc c'est la volonté des électeurs de
faire l'union mais il finit par
l'emporter sur ses représentants mais
les françaises ont été plus unionais ont
été plus pro union que ne l'ont été les
parties puisque finalement c'est saxe a
dit ce vote s'il ya eu autant de déport
et particulièrement dans les derniers
jours de cette campagne du premier tour
c'est que les gens voulaient
ça fait partie des gains sur la
présidentielle on a mal analysé cette
demande qui était vraiment très
importante mais évidemment que puisque
c'est jean luc mélenchon qui a attiré ce
vote là aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de
discussion sur le fait que c est les
filles qui doit mener ces discussions
fait il n'y a pas de doute après ça veut
pas dire qu'on est en compte doit tout
accepter ça veut pas dire qu'on doit
accepter toutes les conditions
évidemment mais ça je crois que ça fait
partie d'une négociation mais je crois
le truc le plus important à mon sens à
entendre c'est que on il ya une volonté
des gens de gauche de écologistes
d'aller vers la victoire et que sa façon
de donner un peu d'espoir mais peuple de
gauche c'est bien ça ne peut pas le
mépriser parce que en tant que
personne de cette démocratie
représentative
il ne faut jamais oublier qui nous
représentons et là ils se sont exprimées
elles se sont exprimées il faut
l'entendre joaillerie d'elle
cette coalition
impossible cette union de la gauche tant
réclamé par par les électeurs par les
militants impossible avant la
présidentielle qui devient possible
aujourd'hui savourer jouer ou pas ah oui
moi ça me réjouis je pense que comme 93
% des électeurs de gauche si on en croit
les derniers sondages on souhaite très
fortement cette coalition souhaite cet
accord on est heureux de voir que des
choses progressent mais je dirais une
chose je pense que vu l'urgence
il faut si vous voulez
éviter de
vouloir tout régler en cinq jours ce don
ce qu'on aurait dû régler depuis cinq
ans en réalité est-ce qu'on peut régler
des noms il ya de l'argent il ya des
chinois sur les drm qui sont construire
l'europe sur la question internationale
sur l'ukraine et sur l'europe sur
l'europe par exemple je pense pas qu'on
puisse régler en cinq jours cette
question encore une fois je pense qu'il
aurait fallu en discuter peut-être pas
depuis cinq ans mais en tout cas depuis
que le parti socialiste en 2018 par
exemple avait parlé de trahison pour
qualifier quinquennat de françois
hollande sur la question européenne
le problème c'est qu'elle est très
symbolique la question l'ade et la
désobéissance elle est très intéressante
mais c'est une question complexe c'est à
dire que
il faut un rapport de force et je je je
ne crois pas du tout qu'il fallait faire
d'équivalence entre la désobéissance par
exemple que prône le rnd droite
identitaire en europe comme certains le
font notamment n'a rien à voir il ya des
d'un côté il ya des gens qui veulent
désobéir sur l'état de droit et de
l'autre il ya des gens qui veulent
désobéir au nom du progrès social et
écologique donc d'un côté vous avez des
gens qui s'assoient sur les valeurs
européennes et de l'autre vous avez des
gens qui au contraire volti être fidèle
là-haut bruxelles ne l'est pas toujours
aimé changer la méthode les variations à
ronfler des naissances la
méthode est proposée sur la question
européenne qui va au delà de de
l'incapacité qu'on a pu avoir ces
dernières années agir andré manseau je
crois que on doit dire aujourd'hui la
maintenant que on sera jamais d'accord
surtout enfin il n'y a pas de secret non
plus là dessus c'est pas l'idée c'est
pas de faire un consensus mou sur une
base qui soit l'idée c'est aussi d'acte
et qu'on puisse avoir des désaccords
avec telle ou telle formation politique
l'important c'est qu'on se dise et qu'on
comprenne comment on va régler ces
désaccords et quelle politique on mène
sur cinq ans que de toute façon sur cinq
ans par exemple si je prends le
nucléaire est ce qu on relance le
programme nucléaire ou est-ce qu'on ne
le relance pas c'est ça la question et
qu'il affiche de jean luc mélenchon
s'est enlisée mois premier ministre donc
cette pollution si vous y croyez peut
éventuellement je ne sais pas ce que ça
arrivera vous portez au gouvernement
donc autant être d'accord avant et c'est
une contrat de confiance avec les on est
d'accord c'est pour ça que les
négociations ont lieu sur le programme
pour qu'on fasse l'essentiel après on
vous dit on a on aurait cinq ans pour se
mettre d'accord non ce que je vous dis
ce que je vous dis c'est qu'on ne peut
pas être d'accord sur tout avec eux par
contre il faut acter nos désaccords et
actes et les méthodes de règlement de
ces désaccords si on est confrontés à
eux c'est tout est-ce que c'est pas 30
ans d'histoire de la gauche qui vont
être résolus par quinze jours entre les
deux tours c'est pas vrai mais ça fait
partie aussi de notre richesse et quant
à la fiche de moi je dois dire que au
moins ça rend très concret le fait qu'il
faille se lever pour aller sur les
législatives aient voté et modifier la
majorité à l'assemblée nationale je
crois qu'il faut pas il faut parler un
peu moins de nous et parler un peu plus
du pays et de la manière dont on peut
gouverner est associé le pays aux
réformes que l'on a envie de porter
ensemble parce que la gauche à des
réformes apportées et des ruptures à
faire moi j'ai l'intuition que ce pays
doit on doit sortir si la gauche
d'étudier peu utile elle doit sortir ce
pays de sa conflictuelle it et internes
et delà de la violence qui est celle des
réseaux sociaux par ailleurs mais qui
aussi traduites dans la réalité et il
nous faut apprendre aux pays à bâtir des
compromis et c'est ça la question qui
est posée dans cette histoire de
coalition nous avons besoin de compromis
un compromis entre le capital et le
travail pour redistribuer la richesse
primaire pas simplement par l'impôt et
d'aider le salaire il faut redistribuer
les richesses il faut des compromis je
reprends un tout bête entre les
chasseurs et les autres usagers de la
nature c'est indispensable avant que ça
se finisse à coups de fusil entre les
uns ont des fusils accord avec un
compromis avec les staffs et fait passer
mais c'est mais peu importe peu importe
ce qu'on en pense les unes et les autres
escales et l'affection on a ou pas pour
cette pratique mais le compromis à tout
prix c'est particulier cette idée d'un
compromis à tout prix parce que la neige
de l'hiver n'est jamais tout le monde
doit bâtir des compromis le problème de
macron c'est qu'il n'a pas bâti de
compromis il a gouverné pendant cinq ans
et je voudrais quand même que mes deux
collègues qui sont là ne confondent pas
les mots compromis et compromissions
c'est le rôle du politique que de
trouver des moyens de vivre ensemble à
des gens qui par plusieurs décennies de
libéralisme de déclassement de d'angoise
diverses et de tensions politiques ne
sont plus capables de les bâtir
eux-mêmes et des compromis on en bâti
tous les jours dans notre vie c'est
comme ça la force centrale on va dire
centre-gauche centre-droit d' emmanuel
macron pour vous elle est moins
cohérente qu'une alliance entre le ps et
les insoumis
si on a l'impression qu'ils sont quand
même eux se retrouvent surtout c'est que
maël maquereau a peut-être bâti des
compromis entre le centre gauche au
centre droit et pour kigali fit même
d'extrême centre ce qui ne me paraît pas
tout à fait la définition du compromis
qu'on n'a jamais eu les carnages elle la
face voilà cet espace lui je n'ai je
n'ai pas vu les compromis qu'il a bâti
avec le pin ni dans la manière dont il a
géré la crise dg des choses eni dans la
manière dont il a conduit le front d
extrême droite leur assemblée nationale
a progressé tout au cours de son
quinquennat donc c'est ça le défi alors
c'est un groupe promis que vous allez
essayer de bâtir qui va forcément
va faire va permettre des clarifications
on commence à le voir au dos mais des
clarifications aussi parce qu'il ya un
certain nombre de démissions qui
commencent à se faire jour au sein du
parti socialiste on l'a écouté pierre
jouve est suivi d'eric coquerel et puis
ensuite vous vous montrerez une lettre
d'un d'un des cadres du ps historique
aujourd'hui nous avons constaté nous
avons constaté qu'il n'y avait pas de
point insurmontable entre nous et qu'il
y avait des convergences possibles est
forte pour construire ensemble un
programme partagé notre impression c'est
qu'on y est gentil rentrer discuter avec
à nouveau parti socialiste voit la
partie soliste qui était en train et
nous l'ont dit très clairement de rompre
avec les années hollande de ropraz avec
le social libéralisme
ça demande confirmation c'est ça qu'on a
ressenti et donc je suppose que
tous les socialistes tous les députés
socialistes actuels ne vont pas embrayé
ce chemin j'ai cru comprendre que
certains noms c'est partir j'ai cru
comprendre que monsieur hollande demain
va s'exprimer pour dire son désaccord
avec eux avec ce qui est en train de se
faire donc il ya des clarifications chez
eux qui est en cours à la salle
clarification elle a commencé laurent je
vais vous montrer la lettre de laurent
azoulai membre du ps depuis 48 ans qui
claquent la porte pourrait y en avoir
beaucoup d'autres qui parlent de vent
mauvais au sein du parti socialiste qui
se subordonnent pour quelques sièges un
parti qui porte en lui et c'est les
insoumis dont il parle les germes de la
désintégration républicaine qu'est ce
que vous lui répondez bon vent partez
clame a dit olivier faure c'est ce qu'il
a dit mais moi je suis pas là
dépositaire éternelle du parti
socialiste envers et contre tout le
parti socialiste il a toujours joué un
rôle dans le rassemblement des gauches
toujours et là les socialistes ils vont
le faire pour ceux qui veulent le faire
il a été ré jour la force dominante de
ré pour vous dire l'avenir je ne sais
pas quand je ne lis pas dans le marc de
café je ne sais pas si cette coalition
donnera envie aux français de la porter
au pouvoir soit j'insiste sur la méthode
parce qu'il va me falloir un moment
donné faire envier aux français les gens
nous regardent que des histoires
s'avancer eux le ps de landwell ps
hollande ça intéresse peut-être coquerel
parce que ça fait des années que le
parti socialiste est leur sujet bien
avant le quinquennat d'hollande mais les
gens ils en ont rien à faire les gens
leur sujet c est ce que tous ces gens
qui sont pas tout à fait d'accord entre
eux vont arriver à construire quelque
chose qui nous donne confiance et qui
donne en qui nous donne envie de les
porter au pouvoir je finis jusqu'à les
échanges après fini juste sur sur une
chose à ce propos de me lie à une gauche
qu'on va qualifier celle autour du nom
populaire qui est une gauche dirigé par
jean luc mélenchon est très incarnée par
jean luc mélenchon il y aura demain une
autre gauche vraiment de gauche à côté
de celle ci qui ne sera pas une gauche
absorbées ou vivant dans la périphérie
qui ne sera pas une province d'union
populaire qui sera le dépassement du ps
une autre appréciation du ps qui serait
lu notre force on est en pleine
recomposition mois dans cette
recomposition je pense qu'il faut jouer
l'intérêt des français c'est à dire
l'intérêt de ceux qui ont souffert du
quinquennat macro et du libéralisme est
aussi il faut leur donner confiance dans
notre capacité à faire ensemble il ya
deux trois sujets qu'il faut qu'on règle
qui sont déterminants pour mourir alors
lesquels l'europe par exonhit les airs
les retraites l'europe le nucléaire les
retraites ont gagné un débat avec le
pays un débat au parlement on verra
qu'elle y aura des forces diverses et on
verra ça me paraît pas être des sujets
compliqués de principe mais une question
simple est ce que demain matin si jean
luc mélenchon est premier ministre on
continue de livrer des armes à l'ukraine
alors ça ça intéresse est important
parce que ça intéresse ça doit vous
parlez aussi et vous répondrais là
dessus ces centrales à londres et un
instant s'entraîneront sont à écouter et
yannick jadot dans toute la campagne qui
est extrêmement clair sur le cren sur ce
sujet là c'est évidemment on aide les
ukrainiens en leur livrant des armes il
a même dit que c'était pas assez loin
assez fort maintenant la france livre de
larmes plus offensive et plus lourde la
condamnation poutine a été sans appel
est ce que vous dites comme laurence
rossignol qu il faut absolument que les
insoumis bouge là dessus les votes et
sur les sanctions contre la russie et
sur l'armement n'ont pas été les vôtres
si haut par la brusque et bien sa
journée d'abord je suis députée
européenne nous avons voté la même chose
les écologistes et nous parlement
européen sur les sanctions oui sur les
sanctions nous avaient voté des
sanctions bien sûr nous avons voté les
sanctions parlement européen nous avons
voté deux résolutions depuis le début du
conflit et nos votes sont identiques à
la loi sur les sanctions et sur
l'arrière des solutions on n'a pas voté
de l'armement en campagne donc en
l'occurrence ça m'a aidé à me lancer
comme important de verdure vous voyez on
arrête qu'à partir nous ont entendus et
de on dit on crée du conflit là où il
n'y en a pas forcément en tant qu on ne
faisait pas un point fondamental pour
vous la question de l'ukraine va bien
sûr surtout qu'elle est d'actualité donc
là il va falloir savoir ce qu'on fait
immédiatement et je pense que les
sanctions économiques ont été portés et
ça vient d'être dit par manon brille par
les insoumis après il y avait sept clamé
de livraison des armes cette livraison
ben oui enfin elle est sûre sur les
sanctions économiques j'ai pas air
entendu qu'ils qu'il s'opposait à sa fin
mais j'ai mal entendu mais parce que
j'ai même demandé d'aller plus loin sur
martins après il ya cette question de
livraisons d'armes mois sur la livraison
d'armes de fait aujourd'hui l'armée
ukrainienne a besoin de ces armes et
donc il nous faut les fournir évidemment
la position de rupture gers et le même
alignement que ça n'est pas une solution
miracle non plus la livraison d'armes
voilà c'est à dire que on a vu en syrie
on a vu en afghanistan ce que ça donne
c'est des armes qui restent dans les
populations pendant très longtemps et ça
a des conséquences sur le moyen et long
terme ce que je dis là c'est que il nous
faut vivre et des armes aujourd'hui pour
gagner cette que le permettre à
l'ukraine de gagner cette guerre qu
après il faudra aussi oui il faudra
aussi avoir un processus de sortie de
cette guerre et que sans doute la
question des armes se reposera et se
reposera avec cette idée que ça n'est
pas la solution magique à tous
maintenant après jour les armes
ça fait partie des choses que nous
discutons dans le cadre des discussions
programmatiques y compris sur la
nécessité d'une sortie à moyen terme du
commandement intégré de l'otan à la fin
de la guerre en ukraine ça fait partie
des choses que vous pourriez bouger la
tête sur lesquels renoncer à sur
lesquels nous avancions c'est pas un
renoncement s'éprendre état du fait de
la situation politique mais si vous
pouvez me permettre de réagir quand même
sur ce qu'a dit laurence rossignol bien
entendu que pour nous l'objectif de
cette campagne il vous l'avez peut-être
remarqué à aucun moment on a eu un mot
vis-à-vis des autres forces politiques
parce que précisément l'objectif était
de convaincre les gens sur des idées et
sur ce qu'on peut faire concrètement
pour changer la vie et je voudrais
insister là dessus parce que j'ai
l'impression parfois que notre
conversation est un peu hors sol est un
peu déconnecté de ce pourquoi on fait ça
si on se tourne vers europe écologie les
verts verts et le parti communiste le
parti socialiste se tournent vers nous
ça a du sens et l'objectif c'est pas
juste faire une tambouille électorale
toi tu vas prendre tel cirque o et toi
tu vas prendre tel sort que se passa
dont on parle et on parle c'est
construire un projet de gouvernement et
j'insiste de gouvernement qui veut dire
qu'on couvre l'ensemble des sujets sur
lesquels un gouvernement est amené à se
prononcer parce qu'on pourra pas
improviser dans les cinq prochaines
années pour changer la vie des gens donc
c'est très concret jean luc mélenchon
premier ministre y signe un décret pour
bloquer les prix de produits des
produits de première nécessité pour
faire le smic à 1400 euros nac savait
qu'il pourrait y avoir peut-être sur
l'embargo sur le gaz russe un vote à
l'assemblée nationale ça pourrait être
une décision soumise aussi aux dés
emmanuel blanc bat un peu tendance à
oublier que l'assemblée nationale a un
rôle à jouer sur les questions
internationales omi voterait pour ou
contre l'embargo ça fera vers le gaz ça
fait ma thèse dont on va discuter en
l'occurrence l'embargo tel qu'il a été
proposé au parlement européen je leur ai
dit puisque peut-être à l'assemblée
nationale vous suivez - lé vote au
parlement européen nous l'avons voté de
manière conjointe y compris avec les
écologistes donc vous voyez qu'un chemin
peut-être trouvé si on n'oublie pas la
boussole qui est la nôtre qui est de
changer la vie des gens et changer la
vie des gens je suis désolé on va pas
trouver un compromis pour dire la
retraite c'est qu'à 60 ans alors qu'on a
fait 22 % sur ce marqueur politique
immense on va pas dire finalement ses 61
ou 62 donc il ya des éléments essentiels
pour transformer la vie des gens et ça
c'est si on le fait c'est pas parce que
on pense qu'on est les plus beaux les
plus forts c'est parce que on pense que
c'est le moyen de changer leurs vies
d'éviter d'avoir des renoncements qu'on
a déjà connu dans le passé en
l'occurrence avec le quinquennat
françois hollande et moi je vais vous
dire mon optimisme et mon espoir comme
personne qui passe beaucoup trop de
temps ces derniers jours et ces
dernières nuits dans ces négociations
mais avec la conviction ferme que si on
a un accord sur un projet de
gouvernement alors tout le reste doit se
débloquer parce que les choses rentrent
possible et ça me serait insupportable
que tout ça capote pour une histoire de
deux circo par là bas ou deux circo part
si je trouve que ce serait pas à la
hauteur du moment et vu les annonces et
qu'on peut avoir sur des éléments il
entend jean luc mélenchon parce qu'elle
n'est pas dans les négociations au
quotidien mélenchon rêve il suit de très
près
et il suit il le veut cet accord il le
veut il le veut mais sans renoncement
sur le fond il peut pas se représenter
dans un mois en disant élisez moi
premier ministre après avoir défendu
pendant un an et demi la retraite à 60
ans et dire non désolé en fête ses 62
lui même et notre mouvement politique
perdrait sa crédibilité
donc voilà pourquoi nous nous attachons
à ces marqueurs politiques forts et à
l'idée d'avoir un programme de
gouvernement et je pense que le premier
tour a permis des clarifications et
qu'il faut se servir de ce premier tour
non pas dans une volonté d'hégémonie
mais dans une construction collective
pour dire en fait c'est possible de ne
pas avoir la république en marge qui
domine la sens nationale 1 5 prochaines
années et ça quand on est de gauche et
qu'on a vécu le dernier second tour ça
donne un peu d'espoir comme chloé rue
dasle la leçon aussi de cette
conversation c'est de vraiment se rendre
compte que ce sont les électeurs qui
décident et là on a le sentiment que
cette union a été tellement tellement
voulu et l'absence du nom tellement déçu
que les représentants et il bouge et il
bouge beaucoup plus vite que l'on aura
pu imaginer non ça bouge très vite dans
le bon sens et comme je disais ça bouche
même encore plus vite c'est-à-dire qu'on
peut pas vouloir tout résoudre en cinq
jours je crois que ça doit pas être
l'objectif mais une fois qu'on aura cet
accord et je crois que ce sera possible
si si je vous écoute tout autour de
cette table il faut aller mobilisés
après l'enjeu majeur c'est que
l'abstention soit la plus faible
possible parce que si l'abstention est
forte là ça devient ça devient
d'ajustement va en parler dans un
instant le mot de la fin laurence
rossignol vous êtes optimiste pour pour
l'aboutissement de ces négociations
pensez que vous aurez une coalition
comme vous dites pour ces législatives
la date butoir c'est la fin de semaine
c'est ça oui au plus tard début de
semaine il faut commencer la campagne
ensuite je souhaite qu'ils aient une
coalition et je souhaite que tous les
français qui veulent que ça change se
retrouvent dans cette coalition et ça ce
n'est pas simplement le ralliement et
quoi qu'on en dise jean luc mélenchon ou
à la l'union populaire ne pas se dédire
la france a soumises qui va nous
conduire à notre crédibilité
collective parce que ces discussions là
elles sont en tout le monde elles sont
elles sont publiques et il faut qu'on
montre aux gens qu'on est capable
d'apaiser ce pays voilà et pour qu on
appelle ce pays il faut qu'on ait une
coalition qui soit elle même apaisé dans
sa méthode dans ce qui demain sera le
plus difficile de gouverner et nous
avons là un gros effort collectif encore
à faire merci beaucoup pour terminer je
voulais absolument clarifier les choses
vous êtes donc candidate s'entraîneront
ce au candidate sur la 9e
circonscription marie vous êtes investi
dans les roues parce qu'on a cru
comprendre et contre-ordres vous l'êtes
sizing d'après ce que je comprends je le
suis et
et c'est bien parce qu'on va pouvoir
commencer cette campagne dès que
l'accord sera conclu et parce qu'on le
doit vraiment je pense qu'on doit aller
vers la corse
quand je dis ça en respectant toutes les
composantes en respectant l'identité des
composantes et en n'allant pas vers un
ralliement mais par contre avec un
accord est un accord qui lève l'espoir
c'est indispensable merci merci à toutes
mesdames je vous garde avec moi chlorés
d'elle parce qu'on va à présent parler
de ce malaise démocratique dont tout le
monde parle une fois de plus révélé par
cette présidentielle alors vous
travaillez depuis des années sur cette
question au sein de l'institut rousseau
et de l'association mieux voter vous
avez des remèdes très concret ça
s'appelle le jugement majoritaire on va
en parler dans le détail juste après ce
petit portrait en forme d'invitation
signé clément méric regarder
si on vous invite chloé ridel c'est
d'abord parce qu'entre voulait nous
c'est une histoire qui remonte à loin
le mercredi après midi je regardais les
débats parlementaires sur sur lcp
j'avais 15 ans je sais pas ça m'est venu
comme ça je serais pas dire
non trêve de plaisanterie si on vous
invite c'est parce qu'aujourd'hui on
s'interroge sur notre démocratie en
crise des citoyens qui ne se sentent
plus représentés
et des électeurs qui sont des motifs
abstention vote blanc ou nul à chaque
élection le mal progresse alors comment
redonner aux français l'envié d'aller
voter
votre réponse à johnny hallyday on va se
pencher dessus dans un instant mais
d'abord votre cv vous êtes comme on dit
une tête bien faite diplômé de sciences
po et de l'ena vous êtes haut
fonctionnaire à bercy mais ce qui nous
intéresse c'est l'autre chloé ridel la
directrice adjointe de l'institut
rousseau un laboratoire d'idées
l'écologiste et surtout la cofondatrice
de mieux voter une association qui
défend un nouveau mode de scrutin le
jugement majoritaire
tiens tiens et si c'était ça votre
réponse à johnny plutôt que d'avoir à
choisir un candidat le jugement
majoritaire nous demande d'évaluer tous
les candidats comment en leur attribuant
à chacun une mention par exemple très
bien bien assez bien passable
insuffisant à rejeter et si demain on
avait un mode de scrutin comme le
jugement majoritaire qui permettait aux
gens de réellement s'exprimer sur ce
qu'ils pensent de la classe politique
dans la nuance dans l'adhésion comme
dans le rejet ça pourrait faire revenir
des gens aux ordres l'idée est plutôt
séduisante sur le papier donner un avis
sur chaque candidat plutôt que d'en
choisir un seul la primaire populaire à
gauche a tenté l'expérience padam
christiane taubira laisse n'a pas
franchement convaincu
il faut dire que ce mode de scrutin peut
aussi donner
dori dans les bureaux de vote le
dépouillement va durer des plombs michel
on a 300 voix pour mais pas totalement
convaincu apprendra aussi 300 voix
contre mais qui trouvent que le projet
pas mal alors on fait quoi d'après toi
michel michel tudor
alors selon vous chloé ridel le problème
vient t-il seulement du mode de scrutin
ce manque dans vie ne viendrait pas
d'abord des idées proposées et des
candidats qui les portent d'ailleurs
vont chloé ridel être candidate un jour
n'en avez vous pas envie
[Musique]
voilà un merci particulier à wake up
studio pour ses extraits du podcast la
vie de ma mère alors peut-être pour
répondre au sujet de clément méric tout
de suite chloé ridel l' envie d'être
candidat de vous-même au législatif qui
viennent aux législatives non pas celle
de ne pas celle ci vous engager en
politique m'engager en politique oui
j'ai l'impression de faire de la
politique alors hors parti hors les murs
comme on dit mais je fais de la
politique quand je milite dans mon
association je fais de la politique
quand je propulsé je porte de nouvelles
idées au sein de l'institut rousseau et
un jour de la course à l'élection a lieu
parce que bien sûr mais j'attendais pour
ça qu'il ya une forme de recomposition
politique à gauche elle arrive
maintenant donc pourquoi pas alors on va
parler justement de votre solution pour
sortir de la crise démocratique déjà
j'aimerais vous entendre sur le
diagnostic parce qu'on entend beaucoup
de choses crise de la représentation
impuissance
du politique des pouvoirs publics on
parle aussi de désaffiliation quel mot
précisément vous mettez sur sur cette
situation qu'on travers cette fatigue
dont tout le monde parle le mot fatigue
est plutôt bien choisi une forme de
malaise aussi je crois la crise
démocratique elle est profonde il ya
déjà des racines qui sont diverses comme
la sanction
c'est quelque chose c'est un phénomène
multifactoriel
moi j'ai choisi il ya quatre ans de
créer l'association de mieux voter avec
d'autres parce que j'ai fait le constat
après l'élection présidentielle de 2017
que le mode de scrutin était chaotique
et qui frustré les électeurs pourquoi
parce qu il les force à voter utile
parce qu'il ne prend pas en compte le
rejet le vote blanc parce que quand deux
candidats sont trop proches
idéologiquement il se neutralisent bref
c'est un mode de scrutin qui
en 2017 et en 2022 l'élection l'a
confirmé à nouveau favoriser une forme
d'abstention pour les électeurs qui sont
dans le rejet et qu'ils n'ont pas envie
d'aller voter pour quelqu'un par défaut
et au pr maurice blanchot edwin quand
même mais en deuxième tour on élimine
quand on choisit premiers candidats
parmi eux 12 on n'exprime pas ses
opinions si on explique on aime tout
autant de candidats on ne peut pas le
dire si on rejette des candidats ne peut
pas bien non plus quand on vote pour un
candidat on ne peut pas dire si on vote
pour ce candidat par adhésion par vote
utile par défaut tout ça ça veut pas
dire la même chose et d'autres modes de
scrutin il additionne des voix qui n'ont
rien à voir donc ils mesurent mal
opinion et il peut aboutir à des
accidents démocratique donc on a fait ce
constat et je pense que fin ce que je
pensais à l'époque c'est qu'il était
urgent de porter dans le débat dans le
débat public la question du mode de
scrutin parce que ça fait par ailleurs
200 ans que les scientifiques nous
disent que le mode de scrutin que nous
utilisons est bardé l'unine ménat et
jusqu'à parler d'un tour majoritaire
jusque mais jusqu'à présent ça posait
pas trop de problèmes pourquoi parce que
vous aviez deux partis politiques qui
faisait 60 80 % des voix donc au second
tour ce qui n'avait pas voté pour un des
deux finalistes trouver à se rassembler
facilement il était encore facile de
faire entrer deux pieds dans le même
sabot mais quand vous avez un système un
paysage politique qui est divisé en
quatre comme en 2010 7 avec quatre
candidats est aujourd'hui entre n'ont
pas l'air très bon call flop parce que
vous mettez l'abstention aussi dans
voilà il ya trois à quatre pieds à faire
rentrer dans le même sabot une classe ça
coince ça coince et ça produit encore
plus de frustration je pense qu'il est
urgent de porter ce débat des modes de
scrutin alternatif plus démocratique
comme le jugement majoritaire mais il y
en a d'autres et je pense que le
jugement majoritaire c'est une
révolution totale les révolutions total
qui a essayé d'être un peu tenté lors de
la primaire populaire c'était
satisfaisant aucune légitimité on a
testé des candidats qui n'étaient même
pas candidat à cette primaire populaire
certes y avait beaucoup de votants mais
pour quel résultat maintenant mais
l'élection était baroque moi je ne
porterai pas de jugement si vous voulez
je n'étais pas membre de la prima
populaire je les ai accompagnés sur le
plan technique et sur l'utilisation de
du mode de scrutin moi le bilan que
j'enfile strictement sur le plan de
l'ange irie technique c'était une
expérience intéressante je dire quatre
cent une personnes ont voté avec un mode
de scrutin innovantes jugement
majoritaire il ya aucun problème gens
étaient contents de pouvoir s'exprimer
sur tous les candidats dans la nuit ans
plutôt que d'avoir à choisir un seul
alors qu'il les aime a priori tous il
participe à cette primaire donc c'était
totalement absurde ça aurait été
totalement absurde de ne pas utiliser ce
mode de scrutin largement majoritaire je
crois que les résultats ont été claires
maintenant le processus politique ils
étaient bréhal pour les raisons que vous
mentionnez mais est ce qu'à un risque
avec le jugement majoritaire d'avoir un
candidat élu avec une mention passable
voix c'est bien oui c'est le vix mais
c'est le risque de la démocratie en fait
au moins le mérite du jugement
majoritaire c'est de jeter une lumière
crue sur ce que pensent les électeurs ce
que ne fait pas le mode de scrutin que
l'on utilise dont la vocation est de
fabriquer des majorités et de fabriquer
des plébiscites mais on voit bien que
les gens y croient de moins en moins
parce que je pas si vous avez remarqué
mais depuis dimanche on commente les
résultats de façon assez inédite je
trouve en mentionnant les résultats en
pourcentage des inscrits ont dit
emmanuel macron a fait 38 % des inscrits
ce qui est factuellement juste et on dit
il ya eu 28 % l'abstention et 6 % de
bulletins blancs et nuls c'est à dire
que on a pris acte du fait que notre
mode de scrutin contre élections ne
servent ne n'arrivait plus à fabriquer
on fait quand on est le magnat
australien où la présence na loba
direction de la cité parce que le même
défaut c'est aussi à cause d exil m
est-ce que c'est pas ça le vrai problème
c'est qu'il ya un problème d'offre avec
des populismes avec un problème de
niveau général de ddd programme est-ce
que c'est pas les le pen le problème
plutôt que le mode veille à plaindre les
jeunes je pense que le mode de scrutin à
graver en fait la démonstration c'est
vrai que depuis 2002 et depuis
l'irruption de cette troisième force
l'extrême droite dans la vie politique
le mode de scrutin que nous utilisons
est frustrant parce qu'on doit faire
barrage parce qu'on doit voter utile et
c'est donc égal je pense urgence à la
réformer et si on veut aller faire une
réforme d 2027 et moi je voudrais que ce
soit porté à l'assemblée nationale par
les prochains député qui est un débat
sur le scrute le mode de scrutin
présidentiel pour aller par exemple vers
le vote par approbation qui est un mode
de scrutin très simple où l'électeur
peut soutenir autant candidats qui le
souhaite il peut mettre plusieurs
bulletins dans la même enveloppe
ça permet soit utile ça permet d'éviter
de vote utile on peut un électeur de
gauche pourra soutenir tous les
candidats de gauche qu'ils le souhaitent
donc c'est un progrès concret par
rapport au mode de scrutin qu'on a
actuellement avec un fonctionnement
assez similaires le jugement majoritaire
c'est un cran plus loin c'est beaucoup
plus pour bien comprendre vous avez en
préparant en préparant cette mission je
vous ai lu vous dites qu'au fond avec ce
mode de scrutin le candidat préféré
n'est jamais celui qu'on croit vous
dites qu'en 2002 c'était jospin mais
qu'en 2007 c'était françois bayrou
en gros on de voix au premier tour c'est
pas bon ça non parce qu'en fait en 2002
lionel jospin a été victime d'un
paradoxe scientifique et démocratique
s'appelle le paradoxe d'arreau démontré
par le prix nobel kenneth arrow dans les
années 50 qui dit la chose suivante qui
que dans une élection quand des
candidats sont sur le même la même offre
politique il se neutralisent même si
leurs idées sont majoritaires et ça
c'est pas normal c'est paradoxal jospin
était donné gagnant au second tour et
face à chirac et face à le pen donc dans
toutes les configurations donc il aurait
dû remporter cette élection mais il ne
passe pas le premier tour parce qu'il à
christiane taubira et jean pierre
chevènement qui se présentent sur le
même créneau que lui et qui lui mangent
des voix donc ça c'est paradoxal et le
jugement majoritaire permet de remédier
à ce paradoxe d'arreau puisque vous
n'avez plus de vote utile si vous êtes
de gauche vous pouvez très bien évalué
tous les candidats go le vote par
approbation aussi permet d'éviter ça
donc ce serait un progrès concrets mais
je crois qu'il suffira pas pour remédier
à la crise démocratique de modifier
votre mode de scrutin présidentiel je
pense que la deuxième urgence c'est de
rendre du pouvoir au parlement de
rétablir l'équilibré qui est
complètement détruits depuis le
quinquennat entre l'exécutif et le
législatif et pour ça je pense qu'il ya
deux choses très simples la
proportionnelle il suffit d'une loi est
organisée le même jour le premier tour
de l'élection présidentielle le premier
tour l'élection du siat il pourrait
viser klich latitude ne soit qu'une
validation implication et le phasage des
deux le même jour alors justement le
président de la république l'a identifié
cette crise président réélu il promet de
répondre à la défiance par une nouvelle
méthode plus participative au niveau
local avec plus de consultations il
parle du référendum ils parlent de la
proportionnelle on va l'écouter il était
dans le val d'oise à cergy ce matin
on en redemande moyens
on sait
voilà il va lancer ce qu'il appelle une
grande commission transpartisane avec
des constitutionnalistes avec des grands
élus est-ce que vous pensez que c'est la
bonne méthode la proportionnelle sera
sur la table la question de la
démocratie citoyenne avec plus de
participation au niveau local également
on dit même que on pourrait revenir au
cumul des mandats est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que c'est la bonne manière
de répondre à cette crise oui je crois
que la méthode de la commission
transpartisane et du la concertation
c'est la bonne méthode mais je pense que
c'est la chose la plus urgente qui les
affaires parce que si il repart sur un
quinquennat
d'hyperprésidence solitaire là les
choses vont véritablement traqué compte
tenu de la façon et de la fragilité avec
laquelle il a été il a été élu donc
c'est quelque chose d'urgent à porter
mais je crois que la méthode est plutôt
sous la bonne six français sur dix
favorable à une cohabitation ça c'est un
sondage est là pour bfm tv aujourd'hui
après tout ce qu'on a dit évidemment sur
la coalition ça prend sens mais est ce
que ça vous étonne ou pas qu'est-ce que
ça traduit ça m'étonne pas mais c'est
très ironique en fait vingt ans après le
quinquennat quinquennat qui est une
réforme qui a été mise en place
justement pour éviter la cohabitation
que maintenant on fait 66% des français
sont favorables à une cohabitation ça
montre que cette réforme était une
erreur ça montre que les français
veulent un parlement qui résiste
davantage au président parce qu'il n'est
pas normal dans un pays que le seul
président depuis le quinquennat
concentre toute la légitimité politique
dans le pays
le parlement tire sa légitimité
politique du président enfin je veux
dire c'est pas possible compte tenu de
la façon dont un président élu en
démocratie c'est à dire qu'il peut pas
avoir une majorité la macro est élu avec
38 % des inscrits y a rien d'anormal à
ça en fait tous les présidents dans
l'histoire de la vème ou été élu avec
autour de 40% des inscrits ce qui n'est
pas normal et ce qui est déstabilisant
c'est qu'après cette personne et lui de
cette façon concentre autant de pouvoir
ça c'est malsain et je pense que les
français le comprennent et dernière
question le retour au septennat alors ça
c'est revenu dans le débat public
emmanuel macron on parle marine le pen
on parlait également avec évidemment des
législatives de cinq ans pour créer un
déphasage ça pourrait être une bonne
idée à votre avis pourquoi 20
je un septennat unique à ce moment là
avec des élections parlementaires de mi
mandat pourrait être une solution en
fait les uns quand on touche aux
institutions c'est comme en touche quand
on touche au mode de scrutin c'est de la
mécanique de précision une petite
réforme peuvent avoir d'immenses
conséquences donc je pense qu'il faut
tout les mettre sur la table et les
étudier à tête reposée et est très très
soigneusement merci beaucoup à l'arrivée
c'est passionnant ensemble voilà il est
urgent de changer le système politique
on verra comment président de la
république s'empare de ceux de ce grand
chantier vous rester avec moi c'est
l'heure d'accueillir no1 franchi pour
leur parti pris et ils sont 2 ce soir
deux journalistes joseph macé scaron qui
va nous parler ce soir cuisine politique
et puis vincent eu jeu pour
l'international bien sûr qu'ils nous
parlent de poutine poutine ce soir
ayrault en afrique nos a franchi les
voici bonsoir messieurs merci d'être là
ravi de vous retrouver joseph alors vous
nous vous parler ce soir des tractations
on en parlait beaucoup dans lors de
notre première première discussion
premiers débats qui ont commencé entre
les différents états majors pour les
législatives est-ce qu'il faut y voir
une tambouille ou pas selon vous alors
c'est pas parce que on est mercredi
c'est jour de top chef 1 qui font qu'ils
veulent qu'il faut s'interdire les
métaphores culinaires
il ici à bien un temps où la politique
mérite en effet le mot de tambouille de
cuisine électorale c'est les
législatives vous avez parlé là vous
avez des battus de la manière dont la
france insoumise des couples ps sur son
bios mais tous mettent en oeuvre en fait
la même recette qui est la cuisson à
l'étouffée alors qu'est ce que la
cuisson à l'étouffée alors pour réussi à
la cuisson à l'étouffée et myriam il
faut déposer votre partenaire potentiel
au fond d'une cocotte à fond épais vous
commencez par le couper en petits dés en
prenant contact par exemple avec chacun
des membres comme le fait le député
macro n'ya thierry soler en recevant des
parlementaires républicains à l'elysée
où le rassemblement national en
choisissant de soutenir tel ou tel
dirigeant de reconquête ou la france est
soumise en décidant d'accueillir un élu
écologiste plus aucun autre attention si
vous voulez que votre plat et du goût
myriam il ne faut pas hésiter à ajouter
quelques polémiques bien épicée avant de
refermer hermétiquement le couvercle
puis vous laissez mijoter sur le feu
avec
sur le feu afin que les ingrédients
soient dans leur propre jus après de
longues tractations vous ouvrez le
couvert vous constatez que votre
partenaire a perdu ses graisses
idéologique et à vraiment réduit à la
cuisson voilà alors c'est ça l'intérêt
de cette cuisine politique alors c'est
un intérêt parce que pourquoi les amis
de jean luc mélenchon bas veulent
réduire la présence d'élus ps pourquoi
la république en marre je veux réduire
la présence et ne désirait faire une
place à horizon 2
pourquoi le rassemblement national et
citant adoubé etc les candidats de
reconquête il ya bien sûr la
compétitivité entre les formations
politiques qui aiment bien sur
l'animosité avec tous les noms d'oiseaux
qui ai eu pendant la présidentielle mais
c'est pas ça parce que dans le passé ça
n'a pas empêché les alliances
électorales non la véritable question la
véritable question la vraie raison c'est
l'argent l'argent pourquoi parce que les
législatives détermine les subventions
aux formations politiques pour cinq ans
un problème que vous pourriez et elle
représente ainsi la principale source de
financement public et ça pour cinq ans
donc c'est un enjeu considérable à la
veille d'un quinquennat aux multiples
inconnues est en pleine recomposition
politique mart et voilà beaucoup d'entre
eux sont au bord d'un ferry donc pas
question de laisser des partenaires un
certain faire des provisions de bouche
traversée du désert ou du dessert comme
on voudra mais voilà pourquoi dans
chacun des trois blocs aujourd'hui on ne
veut voir qu'une seule tête de chef
merci merci belle métaphore culinaire
pour cette chronique ce soir joseph
merci de nous rappeler aussi la question
des finances t nerf de la guerre il faut
un pour cent dans 50 circonscriptions
pour toucher les subventions puis je lui
mets et si c'était ça le principal pour
les parties en ce moment vincent alors
vous ne vous emmener en afrique ce soir
vous nous dites poutine n'est pas du
tout perçue comme un dictateur comme on
le voit nous évidemment en europe mais
comme un roi eh bien ce sera moins
digeste mais tout aussi roboratif alors
vu d'occident la messe est dite le
craignent à volodimir zelensky auraient
d'ores et déjà gagné la guerre de
l'image et de l'info à l'ouest il est de
bon ton d'exalter la bravoure de
l'ancien acteur de brocarder l'antihéros
vladimir poutine ses revers militaires
ces postures
anachronique son lexique soviéto et
sarris son faciès bouffi et son
isolement la russie contre le monde
entier illusion d'optique dès lors qu'on
élargit la focale dans maints pays du
sud est plus qu'ailleurs en afrique l'ex
officier du kgb jouit d'un fracassant
regain de popularité
quand il n'espère pas un culte déroutant
3 instantané bangui le 5 mars au coeur
de la capitale centrafricaine une
centaine de manifestants brandissant
drapeaux et pancartes d'impôt russes
sont enquis lit-on ce si la russie sauve
le donbass où c'est la faute à l'otan le
pompon revenant à une banderole ainsi
libellé la russie et centrafrique sic
contre le nazisme addis abeba six
semaines plus tard deuxième instantanée
quelques dizaines de volontaires
éthiopien battent le pavé devant
l'ambassade de la fédération tous à les
entendre brûle de combattre côté russe
entre kharkiv et marioupol troisième
scène de genre le 7 avril new york siège
des nations unies au menu l'exclusion de
moscou du conseil des droits de l'homme
de l'onu 24 pays du continent
s'abstiennent dont le sénégal le
cameroun le niger le togo l'afrique du
sud 11 3 is courageusement de ne pas
prendre part au scrutin tel est le cas
du bénin de la guinée du burkina faso et
9 votre contre citons la rca le mali le
gabon le congo alors comment expliquer
un tel soutien tel phénomène si
surprenant vu d'ici elles sont
ressorties un temps peu de mots une
ardente détestation de l'occident aux
yeux de ces zélotes africain poutine a
le mérite de défier l'amérique et la
france perçus comme les chefs de file de
l'impérialisme les stratèges du kremlin
ont su cultiver et capter à leur profil
intense ressentiment suscité par
l'impasse sécuritaire référence bien sûr
au fléau djihadistes envers sahélienne
et par les échecs de pouvoirs à la
gouvernance au mieux défaillante
soupçonné qui plus est d'être inféodée
aux néo colonialiste pour mener à bien
son travail de sa moscou actionne le
levier d'abord la fourniture d'armement
d'instructeurs et de mercenaires sauce
wagner la moitié environ des 54 pays
d'afrique ont scellé avec la russie un
accord de coopération militaire ensuite
une stratégie d' influence agressive
softpower pas si soft que ça mais
efficace
notamment via les médias locaux entre
édito russe au filet et vidéos
délirantes depuis deux mois circule une
photo par exemple daté de 1973 censée
immortaliser la rencontre dans un camp
d'entraînement tanzanien du jeune
vladimir poutine et du mozambique à
samora machel icône de la lutte pour
l'indépendance et tant pis si le boss du
kremlin était alors étudiant leningrad
et les formateurs de l'époque plus
chinois que russe se tiens voilà du
bidon comme le chanterait pas un
légionnaire reste que moscou a su
réactiver les réseaux tissés au temps de
l'urss avec des élites parvenu çà et là
aux manettes ces milliers d'étudiants
vous savez qui sont passés où jadis par
les universités les académies soviétique
la poutinisation de la junte malienne
par exemple a quelque chose de fascinant
même déni compulsive de la réalité même
complotisme même attrait pour la vérité
alternative l'autre nom du mensonge bien
sûr on peut voir dans ce pacte faustien
passé par l'afrique avec l'ami vlady une
impasse stratégique et un ouvrage moral
il n'empêche quelle que soit l'issue de
l'agression russe en ukraine il laissera
des traces merci infiniment
la toile russe jusqu'au continent
africain c'est incroyable n'a pas la
différence de de perception vous suivez
ces sujets aussi extrêmement préoccupant
je me demande comment cependant de tant
d'années on a laissé le groupe wagner
gangréné comme ça
l'afrique et les zones où nous étions
une prison militaire est-ce qu'on sort
de l'aveuglément est-ce que après cette
guerre
un exemple très bref on aurait pu
centrafricaine j'en ai été le témoin sur
le terrain la france a volé nolens
ouvert la voie à wagner d'abord en
démontant de manière hâtive et au grand
dépit des centrafricains d'ailleurs une
opération qui s'appelle une opération
sans garris donc deux passions
françaises de maintien de la paix autant
que faire se peut et aussi en donnant
son blanc seing à une opération
onusienne qui a permis de lever
l'embargo sur les armes et c'est ainsi
que les russes se sont engouffrés dans
la brèche ont envoyé leur armement leur
instructeur et ont fait de la république
centrafricaine la tête de pont avec
ensuite des offensives sur la bbc dans
le mali et compagnie la russie qui se
devrait de nos faiblesses
avertissements 1 il est lancé merci à
vous merci que les ridelles d'être passé
par le plateau de lcp mieux voter
l'institut rousseau et cette proposition
au débat à l'heure où on questionne nos
institutions de scrutin de jugement
pardon c'est très différent jugement
majoritaire merci josek merci vincent
c'est la fin de cette émission tout de
suite votre soirée documentaire avec un
film une enquête sur les violences
sexuelles dans le sport très belle
soirée à demain
[Musique]